[MUSIC]
So this is the 2014 World Series ring.
Every single full-time member of our staff
got a World Series ring, how cool is that?
>> Giants win!
>> I think we know we're
part of something special.
>> A World Series win for
the San Francisco Giants for
the third time in the last five years.
>> Every April,
when the crowds start coming back in,
when it's the start of the season,
there's this renewed sense of wow.
[MUSIC]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Something I love about working for
the Giants is that we have people
from all different backgrounds and
fields within the team.
I'm not sure that anyone would've said
that there's a job description around
someone who's interested in sports and
real estate, but
that's what I wanted to do.
And I figured out a way to pull
it together to get there, and
I think everyone really has that in them.
[MUSIC]
The most interesting thing to me is
really seeing all of it come together,
and seeing how things like finance,
and engineering, and
law have this really incredible
intersection In urban development.
So the northernmost part of the project
site that is right across from the ball
park is going to be a new five-acre
regional park with waterfront access,
and recreation opportunities,
and retail along the park's edge.
And then there'll be 12 new buildings
with offices, and homes, and restaurants.
60% of the seats in the ballpark have
a view of what's happening on Lot A today.
So imagine in the future when that view,
instead of cars and parking lot,
is of parks, and trees, and
beautiful new homes and buildings.
[MUSIC]
I think what excites me the most
around this sort of work is that
it's going to be part of the city for
hopefully generations to come.
[MUSIC]
One of the things I remember learning
at the GSB was that we actually can
experiment from time to time.
And I have to remind myself of that.
So sometimes when I'm stuck in
a situation, or I don't know
quite how to respond, I'll actively think
to myself, I'm just going to experiment.
I'm going to try something I
don't think I would normally do,
because maybe that'll get me past this.
And sure enough, it usually works.
>> Here comes Pence,
here's the throw, not in time.
>> The biggest thing that I would share
is that if you think there's a place for
you out in the world that doesn't exist
yet and you want to go create it,
you absolutely can.
That doesn't have to be sports,
that doesn't have to be baseball.
That doesn't have to be the niche
intersection of real estate and baseball,
but whatever it is for you, go find that.
And the more you love it,
the better you're going to be.
>> [APPLAUSE]